she is one of the most recognizable and
arguably objectified bodies of Our
Generation having been groomed into a
character-like sex symbol role from a
young age and despite her damning sex
tape scandal and the recent
re-traumatization through the exploit of
Disney plus series Pamela Anderson is
more powerful and inspiring than ever
she was one of the first and most
successful celebrity animal rights
activists recently nailed her
performance on Broadway and has just
signed on with Food Network to host her
very own plant-based cooking show Pamela
with love and with the success of her
new Netflix docu-series Pamela a love
story and her Memoir Pamela with love
the woman is finally taking the
narrative back this is the European so
let's take a page at a Miss CJ Parker's
plant-based cookbook and attempt to eat
like Pamela Anderson for a day hey
everyone I'm Abby sharp welcome to
Abby's kitchen
[Music]
in today's video I'll be attempting to
eat like vegan activist actress model
author and fellow badass blonde Canadian
Pamela Anderson obviously I think that
videos where people eat exactly like
celebrities or really anyone are
problematic as
because everyone's needs will be unique
so I will simply be using Pam's go-to
meals and recipes to teach gentle
nutrition and build balanced meals that
feel good to me also don't copy what I
eat either because again your needs will
be different but if you're new here
welcome please subscribe to this channel
like right now before you go any further
and don't forget to follow me on Tick
Tock and Instagram at Abby's ketchup let
me hop in here super quick to talk about
my sponsor element as I'm getting older
I've realized how much better I feel
when I'm properly hydrated and yes this
obviously means focusing on drinking a
lot of water every day but this also
means ensuring I'm replenishing
electrolytes too and anytime I speak
with any of my Rd colleagues about
electrolyte supplements we are all in
agreement that element is our go-to so
element is an electrolyte drink mix with
no sugar gluten colors or artificial
ingredients added containing an
evidence-based electrolyte ratio of a
thousand milligram sodium to 200
milligrams potassium and 60 milligrams
magnesium I spent a few months in
Florida this year and I played tennis in
the heat a few days a week and if I
didn't have my element afterwards I kind
of felt off all day ensuring I'm keeping
on top of my fluid and electrolyte needs
helps to regulate hormones nutrient
absorption and fluid balance to reduce
the risk of headaches muscle cramps and
fatigue and it's not just for exercising
heavily outdoors I depended on these
things while I was breastfeeding and if
I drink I always have an electrolyte
drink before bed and even if you're not
doing any extracurriculars some folks
are just kind of salty sweaters and may
need a little more electrolytes to feel
their best my favorite is the watermelon
and when I'm craving something a little
spicy the mango chili totally hits right
now element is offering my viewers a
free sample pack with any order so you
get eight single serving packets free
with any element order this is an ideal
way to try all eight flavors or share
element with a salty friend so you can
get yours at drinkelement.com Abby sharp
and this deal is only available if you
use my link so again go to
d-r-i-n-k-l-m-n-t.com slash ABI sharp to
get yours today the name on
everybody's lips is gonna be happy
oh man it's been a while yeah it's been
a while okay but no joke guys when I was
a musical theater junkie back in the day
I was obsessed with the role of Roxy
heart I would have done anything to play
Roxy so I'm vibing with Pam right now
and I'm very excited about this kind of
like vegetarian heavy day is there a
smoke in my house does it look Smoky my
eyes just deceiving me does it look
Smoky let's take a look here folks okay
so according to Hollywood Life Pamela
said I became vegetarian for
compassionate reasons but the health
benefits are more than I'd hoped for and
she's totally right Abby not that it
takes a rocket scientist to figure out
that vegetables are good for you but can
you use like a brief overview on the
science of the benefit-backed reasons
for a plant-based diet just in case we
got in the Raw carnivore stranglers in
the back there the evidence and support
of eating more plant-based is true
Undisputed well Unleash Your Michaela
Peterson or some kind of tick tock
carnivore recruiting but Risa suggests
that vegan diets tend to be higher in
fiber antioxidants plus vitamins like
potassium folate and antioxidants so
they have been linked to reduced risk of
diabetes cancer and heart disease and
since Pam has credited her diet for her
iconic body we have lots of studies
suggesting that plant-based diets can
also help you lose weight and it doesn't
have to be full vegan Risa suggests that
folks eating more plant-based still saw
greater weight loss outcomes than those
following a Western Standard omnivore
diet so yeah our girl Pam knows what's
up okay so the quick and dirty of
Pamela's diet is that she eats vegan as
we've established and she practices
intermittent fasting so she usually eats
between 10 and 6 PM which is a pretty
common 14-hour fast now another really
interesting factoid that I learned about
Pamela while I was researching her diet
is that she described gaining 25 pounds
while she was writing her Memoir as like
a physical reaction to dealing with the
trauma she describes it as gaining a
puffy suit of armor now according to Pam
here she didn't change her diet other
than maybe having like a little bit more
alcohol so Abby if is it possible to
gain weight that dramatically without
any kind of measurable change the
calorie equation great question Abby and
I know what you're thinking it must be
the fault of the big bad fat storage
hormone cortisol now it is true that
high cortisol levels can play a role in
weight gain so for example one study
found that those with high cortisol
gained 1.12 kilograms over six months
whereas those with lower cortisol gained
0.53 kilograms but cortisol doesn't
necessarily make you automatically gain
fat if it does make you gain weight it's
because it increases appetite and food
cravings if High cortisol actually does
anything metabolically it might actually
say the increase resting metabolic rate
cortisol also doesn't seem to induce
fatigue since it actually releases
ephedrine but we do know that chronic
stress May reduce motivation to exercise
so I'm certainly not discounting
Pamela's lived experience I'm sure she
did gain weight during this very
challenging traumatic time but it was
more likely just because she was
unconsciously eating a bit more or
moving a little bit less due to lack of
motivation and all of that is incredibly
common in times of stress and Trauma
well speaking of cortisol I need my
daily dose of anxiety AKA coffee time
and according to A Healthy Living
magazine Pamela enjoys espresso with
non-dairy creamer and some Agave Agave
definitely has a little bit of a health
Halo as a natural sweetener but Abby is
it actually any better for you than
white sugar
um I guess it kind of depends on your
definition of healthy Agave became
popular because it technically has a
lower glycemic index when compared to
regular table sugar and that's because
it is low in glucose but is high in
fructose in fact it has even more
fructose than high fructose corn syrup
which is ironically one of the most
demonized sweeteners on the market
confusing I know but that's going to
nutrition pseudoscience for you now I go
into detail in the pros and cons of high
fructose corn syrup in my video right
here but in short fructose has
metabolized by the liver and too much
fructose can increase your risk of high
cholesterol type 2 diabetes heart
disease and fatty liver disease
obviously a bit of agave in your coffee
or tea is not going to make or break
your health But ultimately it should be
consumed no differently than regular
table sugar and enjoyed in moderation we
really should have invested in the boob
cup for this one but the bum will do so
this is my favorite non-dairy creamer
it's not super sweet which is why I
really like it because you guys know I
don't really like sweet coffee a little
espresso
a little over that Agave I'm not sure
I'm gonna feel about this because again
I don't like sweet coffee
huh
sweet and strong not my usual coffee
order but she'll do
okay so in pretty much every article
that I read about Pamela's diet she
talks about her love of avocados so
naturally we have to have avocado toast
um but she also told Healthy Living
magazine that she makes her own peanut
butter I mean I know people do it but
why anyways
I'm gonna try I'm gonna put this Amazon
special little food processor situation
to the test no promises here we got our
craft standing by
so let's see how this goes I guess the
benefit is you get to like add as much
salt or sugar or in this case oil
whatever oil you like I don't know I
think it's going to need some oils to
get this going but actually it doesn't
says you don't but we'll see
[Music]
I mean if you're a fan of smooth peanut
butter she's not gonna hit
I'm not I don't want the patience to
just like stand here all day
sign like
five hours later
[Music]
I'm so proud I made peanut butter this
feels like
oh
I can't believe I actually did it I mean
I probably could have done with less oil
too because it's like pretty watery but
I mean for a first attempt I'm really
proud of this
I'm really proud of myself guys feels
like a really big moment for me as a mom
let's toast some bread we are gonna do
lnc oh and savory so sometimes guys you
just can't you can't choose if you want
the sweet or the Savory toast you have
we're gonna peanut butter and maybe some
banana on one and our avocado toast on
the other whoop
all right I picked up some of this just
egg which I've done before and it's like
so easy I think I just microwaved this
right yeah microwave this is just gonna
add a little more protein there's 13
grams in two of these little egg foldies
so we love that for us
let's microwave that [__] up all right
all right moment of truth we got a good
avocado for our Pam
[Music]
oh I feel it she feels yeah gross I
specifically had to order extra avocados
because I'm always so nervous about this
like it's
what I keep keeps me up at night
all right let's get
avocado on the big one smashy smashy
oh she crunchy
this is a Double Toasted
[Applause]
sourdough situation she's delicious
oh there
I can never prefer that
salt
oh that was aggressive and we got our
just egg do we unfold it no I think we
just have to just it's not as aesthetic
as like you know
sunny side up but she'll do and then
this is my favorite you guys have seen
me eat this a lot Curry ketchup it's so
good
it'll just
Gussy that up a little bit
okay and then let's do our sweet Moment
of Truth with our peanut butter it
actually is great I mean I have to taste
it
um
well I mean it helps I put sugar in it
so
that is really good
okay crunchy peanut butter down
okay and Pam is also apparently into
grapefruits tell me you're a 90s icon
without telling me you're a 90s icon
obviously sugar sugar is vegan we love
that
a little
Okay so
whatever raspberry fruit guys this is a
balanced breakfast
oh now that smells so good
a dry but we're gonna work with it it's
been a long time since I brewed a
grapefruit okay this is like a little
bit Circa
2010. there's a fine line between burnt
and
caramelize when it comes to brew laying
I'm just gonna take it right to the edge
nice
I'm ready to eat that
a lot of work for like 10 calories for
the whole thing but delicious all right
let's try these guys sweet shaver
um we go Savory first
I actually like the folded egg too very
convenient and my award-winning peanut
butter
this is a meal guys
wham bam
Thank you Pam
all right got some fuel in the tank
let's talk exercise so panel has been
quoted as saying that she actually
doesn't really work out that much though
there's no question that the woman stays
active she just got off of an impressive
stint on Broadway where she no doubt
clocked countless hours in rehearsals
and on stage and because of where she
lives she's able to get in lots of steps
just like walking around her Garden or
taking the dogs out in fact according to
New York Post while she was performing
in New York City she actually
moonlighted as a dog walker for this
super cute Irish settler named Dash
which kind of makes me think maybe I
should take my own dog for a while Poppy
all right we got the body moving we got
the blood a pumpkin and speaking of
blood pumping I read Pam go on the
record to say eating vegan is great for
blood flow it's an aphrodisiac diet
which suits me perfectly and this is why
Pamela has been one of the most iconic
and arguably most effective vegan
activists of all time she somehow found
a way to utilize her sex icon bombshell
brand to sell animal rights and we are
here for it and well I love this cheeky
sass Abby can you like fact check the
whole aphrodisiac diet thing so so this
is a bit of a marketing statement put
out by Peta a while back when the whole
eating for sexy times was kind of in
Vogue the theory is grounded in the idea
that plant-based foods are typically
rich in nutrients and amino acids
important for blood flow like Arginine
citrulline nitrates and antioxidants and
if it helps get the blood a flowing here
here and here it's also maybe gonna get
things going down there as well and in
theory sure that's true but there's no
hard clinical evidence that any specific
foods are actual aphrodisiacs so we
actually have no clue how many
pomegranates you'd have to eat to like
see a legitimate boost in libido most
foods that are reported to enhance sex
life are those that we associate with
sensuality and stimulating the senses
they're basically foods that help remind
us of sex oysters are wet and slippery
chocolate is sweet and Rich berries are
juicy asparagus beers look kind of like
a dick and avocados look like balls so
if that's turns you on let's make
avocado toast fur days and on that note
let's talk lunch brought To Us by Pam's
seemingly buried old digital cooking
series sensual vegan so I dug deep for
videos from the sensual vegan
um and I found the website to promote
the show itself has sadly been pulled
down but online it was described as a
plant-based cooking show with lots of
sexual innuendos and cleavage and seeing
as Pamela teamed up with a professional
chef I would think they're probably with
some really great plant-based recipes
there and definitely ahead of the time
I'm not even sure when this officially
aired but the recipe photography was
pretty dated so I'm gonna say a while
ago now I did see one article mentioned
that one of the recipes that she would
make on the show was a classic three
bean salad which just happens to be like
one of my favorite plant-based recipes
of all time that said my gut has a hard
time with just like straight up beans
for lunch so I'm gonna throw some other
ingredients in there to balance
everything out let's do it all right
let's drain some beans
I got a combo of chickpeas and red beans
red kidney beans
and like you gotta drain this out of
these if you want to cut down on the
fart Factor
you can add the five hours later name
here too five hours later she's getting
lots of use today I've got
like a barley quinoa mix here I just
cooked
so that goes down that would get like a
little bit more carbs
some beans for our protein some tomatoes
cucumber
and
oh
those are avocado on the loose because
she loves avocado we're gonna just put
that in everything
and everything's going in one bowl I'm
not gonna like make even a dressing
outside the bowl we're gonna just do it
here really super simple folks a little
lemon
little avocado oil
salt pepper
and I got this vegan feta I feel like
vegan cheese is coming a long long way
from the early days
it's more like Chev consistency but I'm
here for it as I said we love a classic
bean salad it's such like a perfect
picnic side but this just is a little
bit more balanced and satiating for me
and a little less likely to aggravate
the old gut so we got healthy fats in
our avocado and avocado oil we got
protein in the quinoa and the beans lots
of fiber in our barley quinoa situation
and all the veg I mean varieties of
spice of life and especially when it
comes to plant foods and our gut
microbiome you want to get as many
options in there as possible so this
looks like a great lunch
The Barley is like really surprisingly
good I love it with the beans
all right let's talk snack here so
obviously Pamela loves her fruits and
vegetables we love that for us and
according to women's day she's a big fan
of cucumbers already checked that box
love celery also pistachios French bread
hummus and Pita and grapefruit and
avocado as we already discussed so I
feel like this calls for a random snack
plate situation let's do it very
important question are you team like
circular cucumber or do you do
strip ready I think you're a psychopath
if you use strips what well we're doing
a combo today just to get people riled
up okay look at that
and you can choose pick your poison Pita
Dippers pistachios
just like my kids
favorite plate
so
we love it hummus
um
just like that
we got protein in our hummus healthy
fats in our pistachios fiber in our veg
this looks delicious and I know Pam
would approve
I'm teasing you with my psychotic choice
the strips just taste better all right
Pamela talk dinner to me so according to
Hollywood Life Pamela makes a mean vegan
Pasta Bolognese and I love anything to
do with pasta so I'm very excited about
this based on what I've read she
typically uses like a vegan ground meat
and we've got like so many of those on
the market today it's probably come a
long way since Pamela started to make
vegan Bolognese Abby I know we talked
about this before but can you quickly
just give us your thoughts on these
kinds of products so one study actually
did the comparison work for us
plant-based ground meat products tend to
have less calories less saturated trans
fats and a little bit more fiber though
the regular beef tends to have more
protein zinc and vitamin B12 the
downside of the faux gram meat of course
is that they tend to be higher in sodium
and other additives which may or may not
be a priority or concern for you I think
they're a great alternative when you're
craving that meaty texture But
ultimately it should not be a consistent
stand-in for Whole Foods so yeah that's
why I often like to go halves these so I
have like half a pack of vegan faux meat
and then I'm going to mix in some canned
lentils super convenient super easy
great source of protein and fiber and it
cuts down on the added sodium and other
additives
so we got our pam pam pam you're saying
pan or Pam I'm saying Pam we got our pan
heating up here a little bit of avocado
oil going down coffee just hit today a
little bit of oil
and I'm just going to saute some
mushrooms here first
mushrooms need lots of salt and pepper
otherwise it tastes like poop let them
soak up the seasoning okay while we do
that we're going half Seas on our pasta
and some zucchini in here for some more
fiber and micronutrients you gotta salt
the [__] out of it
that's going to help to dry out some of
the water so that it's not like a soggy
vegetable mess unless you're going for
that as we did when we did our Meghan
Markle video delicious but I did have to
cheat the recipe because ain't nobody
got time for this all right oh my God
[Music]
I put way too much coffee in My Cup
today
all right I'm gonna move these guys over
a little bit squeeze out our faux meat
some lentils
and because there's already a lot of
salt in the faux meat I don't even think
we need to add anything else in here
just some basic canned sauce because I'm
cheating and that is how we roll for
dinner one pot or in this case pan
there's some pasta oh this looks good
all right I'm gonna just like turn this
off for a second until our pasta is
ready and then we put her together
all right so we Pat
we pat pat okay Pat Pat throw these guys
in
and let's turn her back on
to give her a toss
um
yeah and if you like feel it's a little
dry you can just add a little bit of
starchy cooking water but I kind of like
it thick so like my man
oh man all right let's plate her up all
right we got some vegan cheese actually
tastes like parmesan I'm quite impressed
that's a keeper so this is totally my
kind of dinner it's fast it's easy it's
relatively inexpensive to put together
and I made it all in one pan I think I
might be able to help with a pan Pam
dilemma yeah that'd be great pan yeah
you know what I'm saying but yeah is how
I like to roll I don't even like to
follow a recipe I mean you just kind of
throw some things into a pot and see how
it goes and look at that super well
balanced we got protein in our vegan
meat and our lentils lots of fiber in
the pasta and the veg and some healthy
fats in the cooking oil and the vegan
cheese
and check that out um
it's so good seasoning on point twirl
you for days oh my goodness
so according to People magazine Pamela
is a big fan of the Rose and I'm totally
okay with a little liquid dessert
[Applause]
poppy let's snuggle
pop it
so I'm like vibing with this kind of day
totally my style of eating and cooking
it was easy it was accessible it was
relatively inexpensive it was plant
focus and balanced and my God Rose hello
we love it also I'm so excited about
Pamela's new cooking show I'm going to
resubscribe to Food Network just to
watch it
[Music]
topic but I want to finish the rest of
this documentary so guys if you like
this video be sure to give it the thumbs
up leave me a comment below on Whose
diet you'd like to see me make a day of
eating inspired by subscribe to this
Channel and I'll see you next time on
Abby's kitchen cheers
[Music]